wladimir
ist schritt nächster diskutiert worden
wenn wir das alles
schaffen
ist das schon auftrieb
es ist ja nicht so viele gibt
das bedeutet dass es eine
massenvernichtungswaffe das ist eine
spezielle google handy so das ist mehr
wie möglich gewinnen möglich wurde zu
toppen das ist eine kleine shop versehen
sie stört
italien erneut eine heftige zerstörungen
mit dem tier in deiner stadt
bürgermeister etwas macht es nicht
wir versuchen ein wenig zu machen
die schlecht gebaut die heute zu
erpressen diese ganzen länge weil das
ist ein großer erfolg neben kinder sagen
das ist eine form gesucht
das ist unsere formation
mehr wut gegen so eine adresse dass
seine kampf gegen seine generation
besonders in mariupol sind bereits 80
prozent der grundfläche zerstört
erwartest du
was passiert
ohne zu stören wir sehen von diesen
krieg das ist wieder eine in serie mit
diktatur aufzubauen um reine zu
schließen um diese russischen werde mit
einer wo es gibt keine menschenrechte
gibt keine pressefreiheit wo es gibt
keine unterschrift keinen demokratie
dafür dass ist die preiszahlen der
interessant weil wir kennen auch nicht
führen nicht nur für unsere smart nicht
verloren gehen kann auch für die ganze
moderne welt weil
das in heutiger zeit dass es mir kriegt
man für zwei bewährt gehen deswegen wir
brauchen unterstützung alle demokratien
werden während wir mussten besucher
sieben stunden